so martine looking for his first win of
the season he was short his last timeout
a 5-1 loss to chicago he's made a lot of
starts in his career against the seattle
mariners here comes the payoff to
henniger
and he laces this out towards the
monster and it bangs off the green
hanegar digging for second and
unfortunately dropped at second base
arroyo there as verdugo got the ball in
quickly panager is in scoring position
one down for kyle seeger
catches a lot of the plate and seeger
smashes this midway up the monster
hanigar comes home and scores kyle
seeger slides into second base and he
has put the mariners in front three
batters into this one it's one nothing
caleu into left field for a base hit
seeger will be held at third
2-1 from the southpaw
ground ball sliding stab bogart's nicely
done there and the turn for two
he shoveled it out of the glove to
arroyo
red sox needed that one nothing seattle
the red sox coming up here in the bottom
of the first inning to face veteran left
hander you say kikuchi no record and a
two-nothing to verdugo
going the other way and he slaps a base
head
as he continues to handle left-handers
yeah six-game hitting streak now from
verdugo
engulfs this
a lot of hang time hagerty
gets underneath it that sends verdugo
back to first base two outs two down for
bogarts was it 371 fourth overall two
homers eight rbis who set tied with jd
for the league lead and hits with 26.
turns on that one in a high deep drive
to left field and that ball is way out
of here
as he strikes for number three and the
red sox grab the early lead 2-1
oh did he wait on a breaking ball
beautifully that time five-game hitting
streak now as you can see for bogots
hagerty busy early on and this knocks
him down to his seat and he makes the
catch and that will end the inning
and right through there for strike three
sat him down quickly one gone
back to back one out walks
everything up
and a ground ball right to the feet of
rafael devers up and over and he gets
out of that
well he's been a bit of a houdini early
on red sox leading 2-1
the stretch and the 1-2 best ball strike
three called right at the knees on the
inside corner and you say kikuchi has
his first strikeout tonight
oh badly bounced that one and that is
ball four
so the red sox will have two men on for
[ __ ] hernandez
and play to jp crawford
that's his feet out of first
those two walks get stranded
the pitch number 56.
a wave
from lefty is always very difficult you
don't expect to see it you just don't
expect it you expect it from right
handers all the time but not from
lefties to lefties that's a guy that
gives him a lot of problems left tander
looking for a one two three third inning
and may well get it bow guards up and
over
and they go quickly
jd martinez he bats with one down and
the base is empty
he'll go the other way a high fly ball
to the corner and go back leaping can't
get it that ball gets out of here that's
a home run well he's done that a couple
of times down that right field line he
has struck the pesky pole and now he
tucks one right over the short fence
seven home runs for jd
takes over the club lead adds to his
major league high and runs batted in and
it's three
one red sox
trying to put white away and he does he
struck him out the back door cut of that
time to get the strikeout
another walk to sam hagerty the number
eight hitters so perez has walked the
seven and eight men
a combined four times
crawford batting with two on for the
second time good speed on base two down
this is in the center field for a base
hit de la morris coming home here's the
throw it gets cut off dealing a headlong
slide it's a one-run game
jp crawford with two strikes against him
finds a base hit in center
so samoa coming on to pitch and the game
tightens up martin perez with a
frustrating outing one-two pitch
waved missed and he struck him out yeah
with the split and some emotion there
from the right-hander socks up a run
hit right on a short hop to dylan moore
right place right time feels it cleanly
and you say kikuchi with his first clean
inning of the night
two way man to miss another tough pitch
to strike him out that splitter is nasty
it's
misplayed by dahlbach was scalded by
kyle seeger
had it so firmly it puts him aboard at
first base
and gets him
set a couple of big k's and that's
another one in this inning
[Applause]
that one's going to be cracked toward
the wall
back it goes to verdugo and runner
heading to the third here's the throw
and they're going to tag him out at
third base
seeger cut down
well played by verdugo
off the wall
nothing to it for seattle here
he's got himself a base hit take that
those hits count too those opposite
field hits they count
smashes that one into left field on the
ground
dull back into third puts on the brakes
throw coming in and they're all loaded
up for boston
and for jd martinez roduko's second hit
the base is loaded now with nobody out
then the 1-0 pitch
ground ball to third scooped up by
seeger and the second one onto first and
a double play
and finally does come in to score red
sox do get another one but a double play
and it's 4-2
3-2 pitch
and softly hit but he dunks it down
that'll bring it around a base hit to
score hernandez from third red sox lead
it five to two
takes a little dribble that's a fair
ball isn't it yep
tagged him out he's out at home plate
quick response there by vazquez 5-2
boston
here's the 2-2
strike three called fastball on the
outside corner he blew him away second
punch out for whitlock
and blew him away in
one two three they go
hammers that one for a base hit to right
so
if you were predicting that he was gonna
have three hits you're winning you're
winning you are closing in on a rem dog
signed jersey
2-0 pitch
up the middle
base hit back-to-back singles hard hit
off of newsome now be honest when you
sit home in your living room did you
flinch when that ball was coming you had
to you had to
base it to right that one got by white
here comes verdugo he will score and the
red sox lead at six to two now this is
good heading takes the ball the other
way
base hit driving a run i mean bogey is
on fire tonight
this is stung the opposite way righty
back and just off the base of the wall
renfro with a couple of bobbles
[Applause]
kyle lewis checks in with a double
big pitch from ottavino
and struck him out 95 on the inside
corner to freeze the batter to left
newsome's 2-1
hot smash great play flipped into second
to get the force more laying out and got
the force as he flipped it out of the
glove
outstanding play we go to the night
jammed him with 97 little drop into
right center field for a base hit
he sucks this out to right field kyle
sieger is leaving the yard
what a bomb it comes to the ninth
and the mariners aren't done yet
seeger's third this year has made it a
one-run game at fenway in the ninth
inning
nobody aboard two down in the ninth
and he will stroke that one caught by
bogart stand the ball game
a line drive to end it red sox win it
had to hang on a little too much drama
there in the end but they do win the
game
six to five to snap a two-game skid
red sox now 13-8 they even up the series
had one game apiece